les chéris on va parler des jeux télé et
ce soir vous a sélectionné donc les
meilleures images de jeter 10 ans numéro
20 on commence très fort avec attention
à la marche
attention à la marche est une candidate
qui racontait une anecdote coquine avec
son mari sauf qu'au fur et à mesure de
l'anecdote le mari se rend compte en
fait que cette anecdote elle n'était pas
avec lui regardez aussi la plus folle
que vous ayez faite
enfin la situation un peu cocasse vous
en faisant le tuer si je le dis la mode
fait et puis j'ai proviseur du lycée qui
l'a fait me poursuivre pourquoi trop
visible ici mais on a cassé lavabo des
toilettes du bâtiment semaine il veut
savoir c'est un aliment des landes en
plus des leurs
ils ont également maintenu
c'est sûrement génial et le crown est
tellement gentil son makhzen ou pas il
veut pas le dire au début des gentils et
rigolent et tout franchement j'ai adoré
son mec moi la lima il m'a fait kiffer
regarder gély rigole parce que j'ai dit
c'est qu'à chaque fois que fatou raconte
une anecdote aussi y aller pas en 19e
position
on va passer aussi posé délesté un
candidat qui propose un mot qui brille
un délit de bien particulier et d'un
coup il demande un gamin du public s'il
a une idée il te sera mon huile être
qu'on doit bien le fils je peux vous
dire je suis persuadé que ces jeux fils
de jean michel maire ou un puisse cacher
regardez bien le mot il te selon le mot
mois sachez 18 sél une neuvième c'est
exceptionnel sa grosse grosse rigolade
regarder 19e
cocoon ceci n'est en fait pas mieux
mature matures
la coutume d'un bateau mais il ya un
jeune garçon de blois c'est ça qui me
annoncés saint-élie fagon oui j'étais
cool elle est avec masturber
et je vois et l'a examiné a toujours
trois quatre personnes caponi vendée
supposerait et c'est génial mais bien un
crime passionnel ce confort bon
maintenant à écrire cet enfant il gît là
ils allaient s'en disant voilà
aujourd'hui en 18e position il n'y a pas
très longtemps signé dans tout le monde
veut prendre sa place
nagui a grillé un ado du public qui
s'était absentée c'est un pote à moi
voilà valdi vous allez voir pourquoi
c'est un pote à moi
enfin voila mais à mon avis il n'a pas
tout dit regarde regarde vos questions
dont
[Applaudissements]
tout élève et les membres
ben hatira jazz ou pas
il a soulevé la lunette avant-hier libye
oui ok on peut l'applaudir
et quand on voit sa mine de rien moi
j'en avais il a été faire la grosse
commission avait vu un gars plein de
l'émission comme ça et je suis sûr que
c'est pareil pour vous si vous là je me
dis nagui jamais lui toucher les mois
maintenant
franchement là ça ces décès ne verra
plus poste coronavirus un mobile c'est
un truc de fou ça franchement absolument
tous nos comportements vont changer les
gestes le saint amour devenir compliqué
ça va on sait même pas comment on va se
comporter au quotidien donc oui vous
avez raison tout ça c'est pour ibm avec
sa mode chaque fois je pense à ça
maintenant alors voilà dix septième
position c'est top 20 spéciales jeu vous
pourrez réunir toute la famille on à du
très très lourd et cette vidéo que je
vous montrais en top 10 est elle aurait
pu être dans le top des fous rires qu'il
ya eu il ya quelques jours une candidate
qui parent fous-rires sur jean luc
reichmann dans les 12 coups de midi je
vous le dis je la kiffe de ouf cette
femme je sais pas pourquoi elle parents
fous rires c'est 17e et on est obligé de
tous rigolé quand on voit ça regardez
chez
il savait que vous soyez en prix j'aime
bien vous au report va quand même ça va
aller oui elle est géniale
le père ce we à ce qu'a dit magical tu
adores alors on va passer à la 16e 6 on
est forcément on veut un top 20
spéciales jeu on pouvait pas passer à
côté de motus et tous les mots
improbables que les gens proposent comme
c'était compliqué de choisir on vous a
fait une petite compil de tous les mots
improbables de motus on adore ça ces
seizièmes regarder régalez-vous
testicules t es pays q c'est cénobites
cee n obéit t e
masturber m à st urbain es général si je
peux me permettre c'est tout seul
tripoter terre ipo t es un ace encore en
lice ont plusieurs toujours turluter url
ou dotés eux à est tout seul la biffe
l'esbf elle préfère qui met le doigt
le ld au yes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michael ce coucou je remercie jacques et
michel c'est génial thierry beccaro bien
entendu on passe en 15e position on voit
souvent des candidats de jeu heureux de
voir leurs animateurs a forcément quand
ils viennent chanter et dans à prendre
ou à laisser
on a vu une candidate qui a fait une
révélation assez dingue à arthur regardé
c'était à l'époque ça regardez ça va
bien je vous ai fait des cochonneries
reçoit oui plein qu'est ce que vous avez
fait un oui on sait bien plus c'est
juste trop rêver vous avez de quoi c'est
que dans mes rêves les cochonneries
vous avez fait quoi comme brême on ne
peut pas ainsi nominaux à un petit bout
du rêve
non parce qu'après vous allez le
regretter à retire non mais dites moi je
n'ai rien à regretter j'ai rêvé de vous
tous vous avez deux mois tout nu
et alors alors ça s'est très bien passé
est ce que comme dans la chanson les
draps s'en souviennent que oui c'est
bien mouillé natsu pas le choix c'est
très dur de réagir à ce happening donne
quoi c'était chaud qui a parlé imaging
sur chérie fm on parle pour ne rien dire
on adore 14e position dans questions
pour un champion aussi il y avait des
paires d'extraordinaire impossible de
choisir
on vous a fait un petit melting-pot un
petit pot pourri sans quatrième position
et là je vous dis gros gros gros fous
rires questions pour un champion c'est
14e du top 20 du top 20 des fous rires
des jeux à la télé faire des rigolades
des jeux à la télé regardez top 14 est
égale m6 c'est la théorie de la
relativité perdu son animal saônoise ou
la peur des mecs quel verbe signifie
pousser son cri en parlant de la perdrix
turlutte une pure lui oui quel savant
quel est ce savant natif savon de
marseille
quelles grandes plumes de la queue des
oiseaux doivent leur nom au fait
qu'elles servent à diriger leurs vols
oui mais je ne sais pas les hommes
descendent alors rigoureux dans votre
vie moi non plus ça fait beaucoup quand
même la meilleure pour moi c'est qu'un
savant le savant marseille je crois
qu'il faut que ça roule pas années déjà
du professeur à ou le savons jamais dans
une caisse à marseille allez on va qu'en
troisième position dans le juste prix
avec vincent lagaf je sais pas ce qui se
passait mais je crois que c'est
l'émission télé avec la peep le plus de
chutes au monde
tout le monde se casser la gueule sur le
plateau du juste prix ou qui fait cela
on va pas se mentir vrai qu'on adore les
chiens la semaine prochaine on aura top
20 spéciales chute je pense que vous
allez vous régaler regardez le juste
prix c'est la chute
[Musique]
parlons bien tonneau trottinette accord
nous tranquilles tantinet énervé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
le boucher quoi ne croyez pas
le temps
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vois la droite serait alors tout le
monde va bien à vous inquiétez pas on va
dire oui valérie oui moi justement
pourquoi du juste prix vous avez un
passage vous au juste prix
exactement on là je vous montrerai en
fin d'émission vous allez voir ça c'est
vrai que j'étais dans le public du juste
prix et même j'ai même joué au juste
prix vous verrez ça tout à l'heure ce
sera le petit bonus en 12e position on
va retourner sur le plateau de nagui
avec une question compliquée sauf pour
ceux comme moi qui adore la littérature
et la philosophie
avec ses rues l'intérieur des terres à
des anciennes aux offices il demande à
un candidat de données l'auteur d'une
situation d'une citation et vous allez
voir la réponse ça c'est un truc préféré
aussi la réponse du candidat c'est
improbable
ces numéros 12 des jeux télé regard des
textes écrits en prison en 1930 qui
affirme la non violence est mon premier
article de foi
c'est aussi le dernier article de mon
credo adolf hitler
il est en prison en 1930 donc à peu près
la non-violence et mon premier article
de foi
adolf hitler j'ai bien écouté la phrase
en fait pas trop écouter la paix je vous
confirme mais parce que il faut le
sortir
c'est incroyable quand même si c'est
complètement fou il ya beaucoup de gens
qui oui on aimerait revoir la compil
questions pour un champion va la revoir
dans un oscar arias débat c'est vrai
qu'elle est énorme voilà je joue un jeu
comprend on passe en 11e position le
disais tout à l'heure les candidats aime
bien voir les animateurs en vrai sauf
que quand c'est julien lepers et ben les
gars sont pas toujours sympa pour avec
notre julienc on aime bien regarder mais
voilà ils lui disent ils unissent leurs
vérités et franchement moi moi ça m'a
fait de la peine julien lepers que
j'adore regarder ça c'est 11e c'est très
très fort
l'important c'est de participer oui tout
à fait contents nous avons rencontré en
chair et en os la bassée mais pas que je
suis encore mieux au naturel qu'à la
télévision
non non moi je regardais bien la tête du
cac et d honnête je l'attends ce bec
regardez regardez où le revoir non non
non l'important c'est de participer oui
tout à fait contents nous avoir
rencontrer en chair et en os lambas et
les votes je suis encore mieux au
naturel qu'à la télévision
non j'adore et lemay capella peut juger
alors j'adore ce gars ont agi seul on va
rentrer dans le top 10 dans le top 10
et on revient dans les 12 coups de midi
dans les 12 coups de midi à jean luc
reichmann qui demande à un candidat
le nom d'un maquereau à achat et là le
gars il sort la meilleure vannes de ces
dix dernières années
ça part bien sûr en fous rires regarder
ces numéros deux des tops des jeux télé
regarde
rappel le jeune macro généralement
consommées en marine asa emmanuel moire
[Applaudissements]
il s'est perdu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà monsieur le président je vous
présente mes excuses
madame macro également la 2 3 qu'on est
en train de perdre dans le public de
sortir sa emmanuel macron faits très
graves ou à vélo est l'ol aurait mérité
voilà d'être encore mieux puisque là
c'est en fait qu'on va ça refaire ça
donc on rentre maintenant dans le top 10
si on est en 9e position
on est en 97 sur france 2 et il y avait
un jeu qui s'appelait passe à ton voisin
le principe était simple il fallait en
fait dire un truc dans l'oreille d'un
mec et ça se passe et c'était alexandre
pesle je crois qui a dit que j'aime
beaucoup
c'était donc de faire deviner un mot à
ses voisins sont jamais le prononcer là
le mot c'était une pipe
voilà où pip est évidemment ça part en
vrille regardez numéro 9
l'énorme élan sur le plateau là ça
démarre très très forts de leurs restes
tu n'as plus le choix
le mot ces pipes je suis désolé c'est
leur hasard vraiment le hasard pipe 40
secondes passe à ton voisin
c'est pas une cigarette c'est une
insignia une clope et fume une clope à
une
qui avec de la fumée c'est une une
je sais pas
grand père je suis me parles tu peux tu
peux payer ton copain
quand tu suces du pays cela génial ça
vient ça des braves a pas complète sans
jamais l'avoir parce qu'il ya la
possibilité de faire les choses bien et
on derrière alors à dix alors l alarme
total envers des robes roses mais c'est
normal la romanité bons numéros la halle
énormément sur le plateau là ça démarre
très très forts de leur s tu n'as plus
le choix
le mot ces pipes je suis désolé c'est le
hasard vraiment le hasard pipe 40
secondes passe à ton voisin
c'est pas une cigarette c'est une
civière une clope une flop
il y avait de la fumée céline une
je sais pas dans les grand père en fils
me dit papa tu peux essayer de copains
[Applaudissements]
quand tu suffit pas là je les adore
c'était ce jeu à rapallo c'était une
bonne idée huitième position du top du
jeu télé vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à dos à nous suivre et là il y
en a beaucoup qui nous rejoignent à
cette heure-ci numéro 8 c vous souvenez
de cédric et bastien dans questions pour
un champion
alors c'était les forcenés qui
s'excitent ai je dit qu'ils avaient une
bonne réponse ou un petit peu comme
benjamin castaldi
regardez on a fait une compile ces
cadeaux ça quand les mecs s'excite sur
leur buzzer ces numéros 8 cedh en
question pour un champion regardé notre
avis quelle île abritant la ville de
manille oui j'ai été la capitale du
kenya le pays et les gros dit oui
[Applaudissements]
série ladji doucouré
c'est oui je m'assure oui mais bon ça
c'est bien cédric c ladji doucouré
nouvelles questions lors d'une enquête
quel mot désigne les signes tangibles
qui permet à la police bastien les
indices oui mais à dix ils ont travaillé
d'eysines et on le fait de retourner la
terre a pas de la moblin oui la bourrée
s'est trompé ce bois bravo
pompier bastia franchement la vérité est
ce que vous étiez dans votre état normal
qu'on ait tout ça fait il ya aucun pari
à rien et ouais c'était des vrais
candidats parce qu'il ya plein de gens
qui sont dits un pari un prix il était
juste à fort et c'était numéro 8
c'était exceptionnel dans les amours ses
numéros 7 texte demande à un mec
ce qui lui manque le plus depuis qu'il
est en couple et le garçon il aurait pu
répondre les soirées entre potes aux
autres mais non il a mis une angoisse à
ça mais vous allez voir c'est c'est une
horreur regarder thierry qu avez-vous dû
abandonner lorsque vous l'avez rencontré
j'ai quitté mon pays et qui vous manque
aujourd'hui
temarii qui me manque aujourd'hui visite
en faut deux choses
ouais je dirais
allez j'ai quitté mon pays alors mon ex
kate bush c'est vrai que c'est très dur
c'est vous qui regardez cela étant ça à
mon avis ça c'est fini après démission
hélas assure sam est une histoire on est
en sixième position maintenant des jeux
télé et là encore aux états unis avec le
mec le plus classe du monde dans good to
be a millionaire qui veut gagner des
millions
le gars est sur la question à un million
il prend un joker pas pour l'aider mais
regarder pourquoi ça signifie qu'on a eu
pour moi on était obligé de le mettre
dans les jeux télé c'est exceptionnel ça
c'est digne d'un film
regardez
[Applaudissements]
j
je
[Musique]
katainen et soini maynard alice
griffonné l'état
d
et ce budget a été exceptionnel alaoui
est franchement moi j'appelle ça m'a dit
moi j'appelle mon père je l'avais dit
vas-y va chercher sur google freins les
série numéro 5 dans les jus il dans les
jeux cultes qu'on a eu en france il y
avait bien sûr le maillon faible et je
sais pas si c'est l'ambiance du plateau
les lunettes de laurence boccolini ou
quoi mais les candidats perdent et très
vite leurs moyens regarder et ça donnait
les moments exceptionnels ces numéros 5
et partage la vie de tarzan avec le
cancer quelle autre signe du zodiaque
occidentale commence par un c
sagittaire leucate quel nom donne ton à
la femelle du singe quel que soit son
espèce la singette non la guenon quelle
est la semaine du lièvre
diffus mais en de paris de 77 à 81 15 ou
dans quel pays le chewing gum at il été
inventée hollywood
whissell c'est le meilleur louis celle
des maires de paris louis 16 chf attendu
général et aux pongistes quatre premiers
et on va parler jean luc reichmann jean
luc reichmann dans ces jeux il est
extrêmement complice avec les candidats
et dans attention à la marche il a posé
la fameuse question un enfant comment on
fait les bébés
la réponse est mignonne jusqu'à ce qu'à
un moment l'enfant dérape regard des
amants ils à tristan qui voudraient nous
raconter sa version raconte tristan et
bien qu'en mai les parents il se fait un
bisou on est bine après s'ils font
l'amour et banias et à la douane du
peuple à qui rentrent dans la bouche de
la main
et encore un enfant caché du smrc encore
y en a beaucoup il ya la beauty à les
choses inventées dans le top 3 des jeux
dans le top 3 des jeux dans le
millionnaire s'était présentée par
philippe risoli
on a acheté un billet de millionnaires
est en fait si on avait trois télés on
s'adapte à la télé et on pouvait gagner
200 mille à un million de francs s'est
élevé dé francs époque alors dans le
millionnaire présenté par philippe
risoli il est un candidat qui est parti
dans un fou rire on a cru pendant des
années que c'était un sketch moi j'avais
complètement oublié cette image
regardez ces numéros 3 ça c'est
énormissime et je vous le dis ça n'est
pas un sketch c'est un vrai candidat
c'est numéro trois du jeu télé regarde
du millionnaire et qui peut-être bonjour
marges
je vais vous des définitions mais
sérieuse il faut trouver l'injure
correspondante corps où on essaye au
wharf regard ce qu'on veut comme ça
résultat et parce que ça va donner
[Rires]
et pas question de s'amuser ça on y voit
en moi je vous dis ouverture cadre
angulaire pratiqué dans la muraille des
vaisseaux de guerre et ses encours de
passage à la bouche des canons c'est un
trou puis c'est tout et tout ce qui
était génial dont je sais que la
mécanique était super simple à contenir
deux sauts et je comprends pas ces
disparus je sais bien risque énorme et
pascal voilà en numéro 2 c'est un moment
magique qu'on adore top 2 c'est une dame
que vincent lagaf a eu au téléphone dans
le big thing et lui demande la
particularité d'un visage rubicond
sauf que la fab au téléphone à mon avis
et à la p11 rapidement un apéro avec
jean michel maire au moins regarder elle
est géniale
ces numéros dont on pouvait pas passer à
côté de cet extrait c'est parti je vous
dérange non pelle club puis je connais
votre prénom auchan l'âme malgré ou
en deux mots en deux mots en 2000 elle
rit oui mais votre prénom lui même et
gisèle gisèle vous êtes tout seul à la
maison la wii enfin d'accord elle a
écouté la question elle et moi j ai les
bétons celle là voyez oui il ya des fois
et les trucs qui vous arrive dans la
ville et ben là on est en plein fouet et
c'est moi qui doit assurer les monocytes
bouger bozizé je veuille ou du tout
quelle est la particularité d'un visage
rubicond
jean d'esme coin à 90 gisèle gisèle je
plaisante pas je vous posez votre bière
gisèle bon gisèle faut y aller
maintenant lâché obligé d'interrompre
cette régulation pardo un cheval noir
oui normalement
normalement dans quelques secondes yens
et l'euro a dit monfils
non mais nous là on a vu le bigdil on va
découvrir le numéro 1 des jeux télé dans
un instant mais faut savoir que moi ma
première télé je les avais fait chez
nagui
c'était dans que le meilleur gagne on
n'arrive pas à retrouver les images on
est en train d'y rechercher on a même
appelé nagui mais je crois valérie que
vous avez retrouvé au passage c'était
dans le juste prix j'étais dans le
public avec un pote on n'arrêtait pas de
crier et philippe risoli étant donné
qu'on n'arrêtait pas de crier il nous a
fait venir sur le bateau parce que il
faut savoir qu'à l'époque il
enregistrait d'abord la semaine avec la
vitrine et après on était il est la
semaine d'après donc regarder sa voix la
ccc c'est pas dans le classement voilà
mais c'était juste pour vous faire un
petit kif et regardez bien matheux t et
la tête de mon copain olivier galison il
s'appelle qu'elle travaille avec des
téléphones
il est exceptionnel la coupe regarder ça
ça c'est hors concours
il s'appelle votre copain thierry
commente cyril bien sûr on est seul on
aime bien la même ambiance on va en
faire des interviews de carlos à vous
faites la même ambiance que celle que
vous mettez dans le public actuellement
carlos bonjour
li jun et où carlos je viens d'un verre
les temps ouais en berbère des tons
berre l'étang
[Applaudissements]
et
ça me fait rire et vous a gagné quoi
cette semaine car l'on j'ai gagné un
caméscope
ouais quelle bonne dame ensevelie et
déjà faire de telle l époque ou pas mais
même pas non mais moi j'étais venu comme
ça voilà pour quitter un peu pour voir
comment ça se passe et la télé on était
très très très agitée j'ai dit rentrée
dit moi je vais dire ma mère j'ai
rencontré philippe risoli j'étais comme
un fou raide ma mère m'a dit vas-y tu es
toi va travailler on va revoir et on va
voir le top 1 le top 1 là vous vous
dites c'est bizarre il est 21h 18 et
n'ont toujours pas été en belgique et
bien la belgique bien puisqu'avec un
candidat du juste prix magique on est
sur la dernière épreuve il doit deviner
le montant de la vitrine et tout part en
sucette c'est certainement l'image la
plus culte des jeux télé quand même un
numéro
ça c'est incroyable vous la connaissez
un on attendait on la connaît mais on
n'a qu'une envie c'est de la revoir et
je suis venu aussi c'est pareil
regarde 1995 s'est plus retourné 299
c'est -14 8 290 8 qui a fait quoi
maintenant qu'il est au sommet
c'est quoi le nom trélazé louis xiii
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a gagné la vitrine là il a gagné la
[ __ ] me blesser c'est exceptionnel
valérie comme chaque soir je me tourne
vers vous vous êtes la porte parole des
téléspectateurs est ce que vous avez une
image que voulait revoir
qu'est ce que vous retenez je crois
qu'on peut pas passer à côté de la
compil de questions pour un champion cei
a je suis d'accord avec vous la copie
qu'ils nous rejoignent et seulement
maintenant regarder sectionnelles et
après moi je vais juste me faire un
petit plaisir juste après à égal m6
c'est la théorie de la relativité perdu
son animal saônoise ou la pire dit mais
qu'est quel verbe signifie pousser son
cri en parlant de la perdrix turlutte
une turlute mais quelle savant quel est
ce savant natif savon de marseille
quelles grandes plumes de la queue des
oiseaux doivent leur nom au fait
qu'elles servent à diriger leurs vols
oui je ne sais pas les hommes descendent
alors rigoureux dans votre vie moi non
plus
c'est beaucoup quand même
à juste raison
raymond d'autres amis notre wenger qui
me dit est ce qu'on peut revoir ton
image dans le juste prix parce qu'il m'a
dit tu fais déjà des têtes de suspense
donc un beau boulot qui dit ça aussi sur
les réseaux donc est-ce qu'on peut
revoir l'image
regardez c'était ma première des dons je
te prie juste pour voir si je fais
vraiment des têtes de suspense regardez
ici mais ça va mal votre copain c'est
une commande cyril bien sûr non
seulement vous aime faire la même
ambiance on va en faire des interviews
de carlos et vous faites la même
ambiance que celle que vous mettez dans
le public actuellement carlos bonjour
li jun et où carlos je reviendrai vers
l'étang ouais envers les néo
berre-l'etang berre l'étang
[Applaudissements]
ça me fait rire et vous a gagné quoi
cette semaine car l'eau j'ai gagné un
caméscope
ouais voilà donc assez pour lutter et
c'est vrai la réponse est bon que je
vais peut-être deux suspects je vous
appelle à la démission par l'extrait qui
pour moi est numéro 1 c'est dans les 12
coups de midi
c'est quand jean luc reichmann demande
le nom d'un maquereau
franchement pour moi sallaumines et j'ai
envie de terminer la semaine là dessus
regardez pour moi c'est le number one du
rib nissan numéro 1 voix regarde comment
s'appelle le jeune macro généralement
consommées en marie la salle manuel
[Applaudissements]
seydoux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà monsieur le président je vous
présente mes excuses
madame macro également jeune lena 2,3
qu'on est en train de perdre dans le
public
mais voilà